so what's your paypal matt we gotta put
your paypal in there
um what do i say well well if you're
serious we'll give you the paypal at the
end
but it's signed by cox if you're ready
to send two thousand dollars right now
i'll send you the paypal right now
yeah cash app man cops yeah they're full
of [ __ ] they're just trolling yeah
i do have cash yeah oh yeah everybody
got cash i do have cash out
do you want to just put your name in
there and if he drops it then
he said send the paypal email yeah here
here's matt
let's give your cash app that's that's
the best way to do that yeah
[ __ ] they might just donate your money
in i have paypal okay well tell me your
paypal email
all right right now let's see
do you want to tell it to everybody yeah
well yeah yeah like you said so
you send them the money all right so
they can rob you through paypal yeah can
they
i don't know i'm sure they can danny got
hacked yes
that was you yeah no not my paypal no
what got hacked your instagram oh what
the [ __ ] does that do with paypal
i'm sure they could hack paypal too yeah
i'm sure anything can get hacked
so what are you saying oh my god dude
we're talking about cats i said you got
hacked you got hacked
you are a hacker so what's up matt did
you where where did you get back from
utah
yes what were you doing in utah
um hey wait a second yeah we got
mountain dews on deck oh yeah look at a
little mini boy
i just sent it to you we got mountain
dews we're rolling
who i just sent it to you that's fine
what were you doing in no no
not only accepts bitcoin you need a
smaller cookie for that thing
what was i doing in utah yeah um i was
doing videos based on uh
on uh for uh some guys that are selling
a series
oh really they're creating like a series
around how to not get ripped off in real
estate and different types of frauds
that are committed
and it's all it's a whole thing they're
gonna sell them to um
uh real estate investment clubs around
the country i mean it's pretty cool
it was pretty cool and the guy the one
guy is named
he's a real estate investor he does
what's called um you know he has
wholesaling you know wholesaling
so he both of them are wholesalers and
uh
so we did a whole like a whole series of
videos and
ben actually has a youtube channel who
does ben
because ben he's one of the guys that
was the uh
real estate investor that flew me out
there
super cool guy see he took his whole
family and they
sailed around like the caribbean for
like a year
for like two or three i think for like a
year or two wow now he's driving
now he's got him all in an rv driving
him around the country
and he was in utah and so they flew me
out there what what is that what's he
laughing at what is it these comments
are how [ __ ] high are you this guy
said matt only accepts social security
numbers
some of these guys get really creative
some
i've heard some of the funniest [ __ ]
from these guys
listen everybody that when i say hey go
buy a t-shirt you know they oh almost
half of them come back
bro i'll buy a t-shirt if you make one
that says i have matt cox i got a fine
arts degree
i'm like come on so you're assuming i'm
gary salton did you make a shirt that
says you're assuming i'm gary sullivan
oh yeah
well that's cool what else you've been
doing you've been making like
uh new content for your youtube channel
some reviews reviewing con movies
yeah yeah yeah i mean but
i don't have any subscribers you know i
got like 14 000 subscribers i need
a bunch of i need subscribers you got
what 14 000 yeah 14 000 subscribers
so yeah the problem is is that people
subscribe and they don't hit the
um the button that no the notify button
so they don't watch their notifications
you got to turn on the notifications so
he said 200 220 cents
he sent me five bucks oh [ __ ] your
paypal's gonna start going off
nice no i think this is probably the guy
that was gonna send me two
two thousand dollars just in five bucks
somebody just said they sent you two
thousand two hundred and twenty dollars
that's the guy no well
he got five bucks so i got five bucks
shane right who was that
sean sean yeah s-e-a-n
scene i can't [ __ ] see shawn
i i listen not just that i need glasses
you know how long it took me to get
glasses in prison
how long almost two years
from the first time i i actually sent
sending a cop out saying hey look i
think i need to have my eyes checked
two years before i actually got glasses
and when i got i don't take so long
i don't know they don't care they don't
care they love you they lost the cop out
twice
and they don't give a [ __ ] they don't
care lost the cop out twice then i had
to file a
um i had to file a grievance then i had
just went on and on bro
what no you guys keep talking no i want
to hear it what
you should get in only fans because they
want to see high quality pictures of
your hair
transplant roots how did we talk about
we didn't we were talking about that
earlier yeah i know i didn't i didn't
realize
i thought it was like luke said like
astro turf i thought that when they when
they put the hair in there
it just sits there like astroturf
doesn't grow you're stuck with this
hairstyle yeah and you have to make the
rest of your hair match that by
constantly cutting like the back
no they they they so explain to us
exactly so they put there's got to be a
youtube video right
they actually sent the money get more
money
somebody else was that five bucks five
more bucks damn that
nice ten bucks so no what it is is
they look they cut a strip out of the
back of your head yeah like the actual
hair underneath your hair everybody's
hair they have little follicles yeah
those little like
little clear white things on the end of
your hair right they look like little
when you yank a piece of hair out
little baby pieces of rice yeah and
those grow
so you could literally cut your hair out
like you could cut a strip of your hair
out
and plant it on your stomach or whatever
and that hair would grow
long just like the hair on your head it
would grow 5 10 15 inches long
because that's what that follicle does
unlike your hair and hair which is
constantly falling out
so they take those same follicles and
they re-implant them
in your hair wherever you want they
could have done a big circle on my
forehead i'd have a big unicorn i'd look
like a unicorn right i could weave it
and i got one one that was 18. listen
did you know people are doing it now
where they actually in they actually put
it into because they don't
guys like don't have a good hairline for
their facial hair and they'll actually
having it done
on their face that's just over the top
um that's just too much that's just too
much for matt they did it once
that's coming from a guy who wanted to
get leg extensions
that's too much you got to draw a line
somewhere
you know it's fun it's funny saying all
this with a full head of hair and being
six foot tall is vastly different than
being my height
and going bald anyway i'm just working
with what i was blessed with yeah you
better hope you get boy
but i hope you keep that nice you got a
nice big mop but you're still young
how old are you 32. oh my yeah bro
listen it could be all over in like five
ten years it starts going
all of it's over it's all about
i don't think that could happen i don't
think you could have hair that's like
super thick
and then all of a sudden hit the kick
and just like lose it all he would have
lost it by now yeah no
i remember the picture receding and
receding with the long hair
i had great hair when i was younger yeah
but it's a gradual thing i don't think
it just
all of a sudden you start going thin you
could recede right
i receded to the point where it was just
it was ridiculous i had my the
girlfriend i was dating was slipping in
like hair club for men's stuff for me
in my books and stuff i was like what
and she's like really you got to do
something i'm like are you well that's a
red flag that you probably shouldn't be
with that [ __ ]
no no i wasn't here let me change she
actually like you how you are
she actually eventually uh started
sleeping with her boss
anyway but they're happily married to
this day and you know good for her
so he had good hair too
well he was also six foot tall and had a
lot of money and i was struggling
so um uh holy oh [ __ ]
look 13 13 cents it's just mean
yeah it just means that it's funny
um so yeah they re-implant the little
follicles they grow
i had a couple surgeries that's it
and now they grow and it does grow i get
my hair cut all the time
i need one more surgery i really need it
how are we gonna do this if like a
hundred people send you
all this money that adds up to 600 how
are you gonna you're gonna have to cut
this thing into pieces and shipping now
somebody's gotta
somebody's got to send an amount i don't
think anybody's going to buy that for
600 bucks or you've got to be kidding me
do you think somebody will are you
serious i [ __ ] sell it for
ice 1500 sorry thousand
thousand i've sold them for seven fifty
hundred i'm only selling that
that was for me i'm only selling that
for 600 because
okay i'm [ __ ] going under okay so
trust me
you saw the one i did of the trump one
that was 1400
remember i sent it to you you said you
got to do one
is that where he's dressed like scarface
oh he's
is he like he's not really scarface he
is in black
he's in a black thing and he's got he's
got a um a gun a gun an uzi in
washington's behind him okay yeah i
remember 1400 did somebody
specifically request that or did you
just make that no guy
guy requested it okay so someone can
just request whatever they want and you
can make it for them
i mean yeah if i want to do it i mean
it's you know it's got to be something
within a reason i'm not going to pay
anything
i'm not really interested in painting i
got a guy right now that
wants me to paint him
with uh griselda blanco behind him
and uh richard krasinski i think is the
guy he was the ice man who did a bunch
of like 30 murders for
the mob or something it's a great
painting
i started it i haven't and he wants this
guy wants himself to be in the painting
in the painting it's really pretty good
it's pretty look i got i did one for um
like seven eight hundred bucks from
pablo escobar yeah i saw the pablo one i
like that one
yeah we should get
we should get one of us with like the
death row album cover
him have matt and put sandy
sandy now uh big black and rob did it
with the bulldog in
through the death of a there oh that
would be sick too
you know i was just thinking i've had
people ask me to paint their dogs i
haven't done it yet yeah
they want their dog painted
you